african music is exploding onto the
world stage
never before have african artists been
as in demand as they are now
afrobeats is making its influence felt
across the globe
as the continent's musicians start
reaching a new international audience
so why is this happening now here's what
some african musicians think
africa has always been next it's just
always been about
when it's all been about time and i
think the time really has come
for most africans to realize that
the gift is here we don't need to go
outside to look for
validation when we can do it here
there's so much more to our music here
and there's so much happening
and a lot of people are taking interest
in what we are doing what we have been
doing
so i think it's just our time so is it
just our time words of optimism and hope
there
about the potential of african musicians
but here's one voice
one big voice urging caution
what i see my biggest fear is that in
the next 10 years
because the scramble for african music
is turning to the scramble for
the land in africa it's i see the same
thing happening
and people are signing deals that they
barely understand and collecting
advances that are selling their souls
[Music]
hello i'm christy mundo welcome to dw
news africa
shuffle through your music playlist
these days and you might find a whole
lot more music from
african artists than you would have a
decade ago for example
it is because africa has burst onto the
global music scene in the last few years
you can
see it in the number of artists from the
continent who have been signed by big
labels in the u.s and
in the presence of some of those labels
back in the motherland
it's actually really big but don't take
my word for it the renowned music
industry magazine billboard said in
february that
africa is the new frontier for the music
industry
and a potential hotbed for future mega
stars on the world stage
today we'll be talking about this moment
for african music
the opportunities and challenges it
presents our first report focuses on one
of the biggest talents on the continent
right now
burna boy his international success has
proved that
very soon the next global pop star could
come out of africa
[Music]
he's arguably africa's most prominent
artist
and now burner boy has crossed over into
the big leagues
under a bed of afrobeat dance hall and
aaron b
tunes his messaging is broad and
includes addressing social and political
concerns
[Music]
this rich blend has won him fans not
just at home in nigeria
but now around the world multiple awards
and a grammy nomination have followed
one of the people behind burner boy's
success has been his manager
who also happens to be his mother and a
key influence on his values as made
clear when she accepted a bet
award on his behalf last year
the message from berna i believe would
be
that every black person should please
remember
that you were africans before you became
anything
else
burner boy has appeared on america's top
nightly tv
shows sold out arenas around the world
and worked with some of the biggest
names in music
yet he's keen to remind his audiences of
where he's coming from
his last album was titled african giant
burner is indeed towering above many
others in a creative and competitive
music scene
his fifth studio album is nearing
completion
another chance for triumph
[Music]
as you heard there burn boy is managed
by his mother
bose ogulu who also goes by the name of
mama berna speaking to us from lagos she
told me how she sees
the future of african music and the
potential pitfalls for new stars
i began by asking what it meant to her
that her son is now one of the most
recognized artists in the world
as a manager it's fulfilling
and just makes you feel like you've done
good work
been surrounded by a really solid team
and you know we have the best product to
sell
he's one of the most talented artists
i've
seen in my life so having him
to work with as a product is is a
blessing
and we all feel very fulfilled and proud
about him personally about what we are
doing
with him about what we're doing for the
continent
and um just about how we've managed to
represent ourselves
i've read a little bit about you and
that you've got a very fascinating life
um you know you had your own career that
you've talked about having to sacrifice
for the sake of your children you're now
you know running your son's career
essentially but i do want to talk about
uh your your your working relationship
right um
because in in 2014 i think it was when
bernard terminated your your
relationship essentially fired you as
his manager one of the one thing he did
say was that he was
he was happy to have his mother and best
friend back right business aside
i wondered if you've now found the
formula of of managing this relationship
professionally
i believe i believe we both found the
formula um
i think it was important that that that
happened
uh because if he didn't fire me he
wouldn't have had
the time to go without me being a part
of his career
even though i mean i confessed i didn't
let go completely i still took care of
the endorsements and
and a few things like that but yes i
think
we both found the formula he's grown
older so there's
there's maturity um he's he's gone
he's gone around the block um so he's
seen
you know and circled back he has a
saying that when everything else fails
you go back home
and you retrace your steps and um you
know
i i've also i've also grown and i've
realized that
you know there need to be boundaries and
respect
and you know where where the mother
child
relationship stops and where the the
business
relationship starts and you know we
respect what we do for each other
and respect each other's you know space
um it's not perfect yet i'm i'm guessing
it can never be
right and i don't think either of us
wants to change it anytime soon
one of the most incredible moments uh
that i think have happened
at any awards show is you getting up on
the bet stage
and accepting the the the beta award on
his behalf on bernabeu's behalf
uh in in 2019 uh and then you went on to
tell the audience that
you know you were he said i want all
black people to know you said you'd
believe burner would want people to know
that
every black person was an african before
they became anything else and we're now
listening to burner's music which some
people
have described as african uh sort of
activism and i wonder was that a
deliberate thing
um or is this a space that you found
yourselves in and how much is the the
policies
the political message important to you
guys
right okay so i was born into a
pan-africanist family
um i could tell you about apartheid when
i was five years old
um so that's my life that's what it's
been that's that's the only way i know
and you raise your kids
with what you know with the values that
have worked for you
so um you know berna and every one of
them
has that i have worked
around africa in my career as a
translator
an interpreter so i know i i speak
literally uh i don't know how many
african languages and four or five
international languages so i've been
you know so i'm in touch with the people
i'm in touch with the land that's who i
am
that's who burn i was raised to be so
that's who he is
so you know if something is your truth
even
if you wake up from sleep you will say
it back to the music now right we're
talking about a time where
um there is there is all this this this
fuss about music from the continent
right
it's partly why bernie is that the big
star he is today
uh people want to hear that sound but as
as you guys grow uh go increasingly
global
um is there is there the chance that
you're going to have to at some point
make some some compromises some
creative compromises to try and fit in
to sort of the mainstream
industry so to say berna
just makes music it doesn't work
from answer to question that doesn't
work for him
he goes into the studio he listens to a
beat it inspires him
and if you look at his cat look he's
done features
with american artists where you don't
even know where he comes from
because he's responding to the music
that's in front of him um he's done
features with
you know south african artists east
african artists
where if you didn't know he was you know
his origins you won't know where he's
from
so we don't really have that kind of
problem with this artist because he has
a range
and because his management understands
him and has a vision
um we're looking we've always looked at
a situation where his music is accepted
on his own terms i mean as
as a manager i can't say after it's been
done
if you have 10 songs i can say okay this
will work better in this environment
that would work better but before he's
done the songs
for us to say listen you need to do a
song
for this person for this market and it
has to sound such-and-such
it's going to just come out all wrong
because it's art
right it's art it has to be art
so that's you know that's that's that's
been our focus and then
you know you asked about african music
and where it is
we've um we've gone on and formed um
spaceship collectives which is a label
it has a label a record
um and a publishing arm which for
us i mean um which i found it
but it's driven by burner and you know
again i have a beautiful team
but the idea for me behind it is that
africans
should own their catalogues because what
i see
my biggest fear is that in the next 10
years because the scramble for african
music
is turning to the scrabble for the land
in africa
it's i see the same thing happening and
people are signing deals that they
barely understand and collecting
advances
that are selling their souls so
we want to push that at least let an
african
be the one to buy your catalogue then
it's easier for you to buy
back you know then you don't have this
problem
of them telling us what to sing and how
we should sound
in the next five years which is bound to
happen
if the people who own your catalogue and
own your career don't understand
what you're about
another challenge facing musicians in
africa as
elsewhere in the world is the
coronavirus crisis
we asked artists in south africa nigeria
and kenya
how the pandemic had changed their
professional lives it seems
for some it is creating real hardship
you know it has affected us greatly um
and first of all the income was uh was
the biggest thing that has
has yeah the profit has affected
and another thing would be all the plans
that have been made
in terms of festivals that were were
scheduled
and all the performances that were
scheduled tours interviews
they had to be cancelled due to the
covet so it had
a bad impact on the music and artists in
general in south africa
it hasn't really made work easy like a
lot of people can come to my studio
there's so lots and lots of you know
restrictions on how many people comes
this pandemic has really affected
us as musicians and really everyone else
being on lockdown
no access to events no possibilities or
brand placements
most brands are holding back on
marketing so even just getting a brand
deal right now
has been tricky um yes
it's been tough but despite such
setbacks
some artists are finding ways to keep
their fans happy
we caught up with ugandan singer spiced
anna to find out how she is managing to
perform and connect with her audience
despite the covered crisis
[Music]
in this live tv show ugandan pop star
spice diana
performs for fans across the country
she misses the big stage but she remains
happy
that she can at least keep the fans
virtually entertained
it feels so good because i know every
fan of spice dinner has been
watching me perform because i know they
miss me on stage
so with such a show it actually keeps
them you know
connected to spice then it makes them
feel like
we actually together or it's maybe live
shop somewhere
[Applause]
[Music]
and that is true of have fun if nambuya
[Music]
she enjoys the show and loves to dance
along
from her home in kampala i just love
everything about the dance but it makes
me crazy it makes me go wild
and when spice came oh it was also
another
another massive show i just enjoyed i
couldn't
i can dance then i sometimes i pause i
watch when she's not on tv
spice diana is mostly busy updating the
social media
she says that the lockdown has got her
more active on the internet
to keep her following engaged i think
things are going to be more digital now
because you know the pandemic has really
helped us
see the value of social media the value
of um
you know um maybe the the
the likes and the following because now
like i've told you some companies have
reached out to me because of my
following
[Music]
despite that diana says that her income
has sharply dropped during the pandemic
just like for most artists
platforms like youtube bring in some
income
but she says that there's not much
ticket sales for live audiences
especially in her country where fans
rarely buy records
[Music]
but when cameras roll that does not seem
to stop spice diana
from giving her best and the fans know
all that too well
it is time to dance
[Music]
i'd so love to go to a spice diana
concert so
she's a real example of how some artists
are getting around the coverage
curveball
but going back to the idea that this is
the moment for the continent's music i
spoke to siport lamini who is
a senior executive at universal music
africa
i began by asking him why that moment is
now
i i think it's just a matter of work
hard work that's been put in by many
artists
producers um and talent across the
continent
and it's beginning to to move into
spaces that it didn't move before i
think the digital
space and the growth of streaming
platforms and the fact that they've
also invested in their presence in
africa
is helping to carry this music and these
stories
farther abroad yeah and and abroad right
is the place where there seems to be
this big appetite for
sound from the continent and what would
you attribute that to
i think um african rhythms have always
been
exciting and historically i think
they've you know
they've been borrowed in bits and pieces
and have influenced
music that has come out of out of the
rest of the world
now people are i think are more curious
and i'm more
um passionate about hearing it from its
source hearing it
the way that it's created in its
fullness from
from artists from from africa it's it's
just a beautiful time it's a beautiful
sound and again i think the the digital
disruption
has enabled it to travel a lot further
than it could during the days of
physical cds
let's talk about doing business and
making money in africa what challenges
do you face i mean this market um
presents its own unique
uh can i call them characteristics right
you talked about streaming and
these various distribution platforms um
you have a lot of challenges there
because data for example is expensive
just talk to us about
doing business and making money uh in in
africa
it is very complicated i mean it's 54
countries
so it's not like it's one country that
has different regions
so you know being able to move money and
make payments into different countries
is a challenge being able to use or
provide
music at the same level of quality in
each market
is complicated an example is spotify
only exists in one country in south
africa
apple music until a few months back was
only available in 16 countries we're
excited and happy that they've expanded
i think it's into 33 countries
but just those basic things have made it
hard
for every market or for every country to
have the same access to music
at the same ease of access and you
mentioned data cost which is a
huge burden and a barrier to people
using streaming
so much so i think south africa is in
the top 10
most expensive countries for data in the
world i just want to take you back to
something you said in the beginning
right you talked about you know the
original sound
um that that people have worked hard to
get african music to where it is today
being recognized on the international
stage one of the biggest things
that can happen to an artist is winning
a grammy sipo
and i wondered when are we going to get
to a place where african artists
are nominated for grammy categories that
are not
best international act
yes look um touch word maybe it's going
to be 2021
um we've had a number of strong releases
and we hope we hope that you know with
the
with the where the grammys being uh what
you know the biggest
and probably the most important annual
music industry awards event
that some of our artists will start
getting the recognition in that space
but you're you're absolutely right there
is great music that is coming out of
africa
you have artists like tiwa savage out of
nigeria doing great
music all the time you have nasty sea
out of south africa
you have saucy seoul out of kenya so the
the talent is there the music quality is
there the song writing is there
the music videos are amazing hopefully
it'll be very soon
um that we get to see them nominated and
possibly win
so what do you think which african
musicians do you reckon are the ones to
watch
right in the comments section or get in
touch with me directly my twitter handle
is at mundo
7. i look forward to hearing from you
today we'll leave you with some more
great sounds from africa
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
if you came all
[Music]
[Music]
crazy people everywhere
[Music]
keep it fresh